international comes that's right with
Anders extensive a top me in san josé costa
rica
the ministry your level concept where you
recently events in venezuela
the club members free new document by
politics all that school am neither had I
and think is a dog
solution so the  goddess of free and afresh
president selections
soon as possible the international can
that group of films i stump rejection of
the use of force
there is no civilians and expression always
die condolence by the families and
friends of the victim's
the group of citizens the security forces to
act met  atmos tourist trains for fight
further los of life and thought frank
you know groups must be disbanded
those responsible for indiscriminate
buyer lens become the hero accountable
de ride who shot protest must be
respected and demonstrations jury my
name violent de club formula kan Dames
arthur violence  against journalist and
then the lions that media freedom
but series specter the period that name
is by figh  t further is collection of
an upgrade that extreme left a
situation for so there is a few it
did historically democracy
roelof flow and separation of powers
current events in accordance with die only'
sustainable way out of the great prizes
is an inclusive democratic and piece
for one  in the framework of the side
already constitution 0 options whether
exactly the shower on political nature
should be sign turned red make this
possibility beautiful remote this national
content club furmilie condens whistled through
this show process is a criminalizing
protest and political aluminum such as
the preceding  initial this time seven
hundred percent it is whether the national
assembly party leaders and members not
to be able to carry out the work gun
in model intimidation and called rivals
the democrats clay is leaking the national
assembly other is president
wanroy do
[ __ ] may 3 in in the  center on the
political live in the country
x constitutional red t-shirt baby bacon
this and in accordanc  e with its national
legislation
the parliament you in ammunition of its
members should be fully guaranteed
in this
regard  integrating imagery to the work
done since the tickle ministerio
declaration the international newspaper that
crept stress is that the best is two
for live in the credible with yoshi the
political process
how we bring that objectif of in the
can't wait to democracy' collections
these  with mynas versions opinion for
confidence building measures such as the
release of politics of business and
change is in the respective drinks of
power
dino de to make them independent and
accountable
the international kan too big how we
continue to support a facility
f word strong and  dropped country to move
in this direction did the national
concert group expresses its the concern
about the suffering on the mine is
a people chose by increasing situation
on the continuous de te relation of the
municipality haarlem circuit
hats leg further excesses
at this low of electricity and water
supply and many have is on the country
in the youth is  de broccoli supports the
ongoing and photos of the na relations
door is stable and effective that one is
not high and response system and to
deliver assistance to those beautiful should
not in this regard shiroso aan de lions
de read not for a substantial
minute its in response true  is come along
so rides with nothing and influence compliance
we that minute harry and principles and we
it restless foot is 6
one two of the launcher assembler is
important and urgent that you didn't have me
no organizations off embedded yew
and can prefer effective members and
significantly more players
stance in writing must rise
from any political interference
international newspaper that clock to mens de
progres me  since islas measurement in the
functioning of the minute its in
response systems working under the
umbrella if i mortgage ordina
sean
i operational assistance and in the
delivery half minute high and support
to people and neat and notes thing be
contribution of the international it
comes  appeal that is efforts however the
implementation capacité is steel week
comes outside the school or not
the international newspaper that is right
for goals for further steps to
facility establishment of additional
specialized national and international
danny sessions sympathetic le
international and growth in the country
and to facilities  fold because if you don't give me
her in operations on the ground in
accordance with comb I threw my but
the roles of the
actors full on this commitment and to step
up work in support at the people
web pages and thick operational
assistance on the international side
it  crawled with setup and you not me high
and working group in cara  cas
de group chose from donors usually
contributions de dan also community for
coordinates more effectively and
international  ze duty
and responsibilities
kon tribute de creating the conditions
for democracy roelof flow and human
rights to prevail in venezuela
in this respect he ving review the
nothing you can blush en sjofar
international van de group has decided
to continue york juice toe periodically wel
assessment of problem  join
international account with red is
preparation for the tick and mission the
political level in caracas to present
and this cache concrete options for the
gun and democratic solution to
this price is certain national fund ending
will be two games continuously we these
regional and international partners
like  politics all who is for a
democrat  t i solution
i become chance the participium or cover and
minister of foreign affairs
the prime minister on such kitts and nevis
in the scapa city of cheddar caricom the
secretary general of the herbs came and
the recent part of the police in that
old week  session of this meeting today i
do so balkans and access the invitation
stan dit bij de lima group of countries
to meet the death decided to do to have
similar exchanges we het caricom
countries and other
wel event interlock it so the group a
social decided to kon  find and the
ministry level in the near future to
assess development and the site maxed out
dot